everyone welcome to day three of the
workshop uh we're gonna switch topics a
little bit today we've been talking
about uh privacy and civic participation
today we will move more into uh sort of
trustworthy uh algorithm design and
machine learning we'll talk about
fairness interpretability and as well as
some applications into Healthcare today
and then going into tomorrow so it's my
pleasure to introduce our first Speaker
today Duba ziani is an assistant
professor at Georgia Tech and he has
done a variety of different things in
the space of ethical Computing so thank
you yeah uh thanks a lot for having me
like we're excited to be here today so
like today I'm going to tell you about
working like pipeline interventions it's
uh like joint work with uh some of my
collaborators and fans of ishwar
national
and Aaron Roth
um and you know so basically today I'm
going to tell you about preparedness I
think a lot of you guys were in the room
right now are here because you care
about fairness so you know like nothing
too surprising here
um
but like the kind of like point that I
want to
try to make to begin this talk is that
yeah okay we should actually care about
fairness in practice because nowadays
we're using algorithms and machine
learning to make a lot of like really
important like possibly life altering
decisions about people and we know these
decisions can often be made in a very
unfair manner
um so you know like an example of this
for example is told that there are still
today like really persistent disparities
when it comes to access to mortgages and
Loans
um across different populations and you
know this is really a setting where
machine learning actually gets to play a
role because well you know that your
likeliness to actually get a loan is
going to depend on your credit score so
it's kind of like a black box hard to
understand machine learning algorithm uh
you know like Banks when they also make
decisions they have like their own
algorithm they have their own decision
trees they're going to be using to
decide whether someone is going to get a
loan or not and you know that can
actually algorithms are applied in
arguably even higher Stakes settings uh
one of them is kind of like policing
pre-exist printing composing and address
the system and so like once again here
we know there are really big disparities
across different populations and once
again this is a setting in which people
actually kind of like use algorithms to
kind of like make decisions
um like one thing that I'm sure you've
heard about is like there are algorithms
that kind of like
try to predict where crime is actually
alternate like where crime is going to
happen and use that to kind of like
allocate police resources like this kind
of machine learning based algorithms
um there's even algorithms now that are
used to inform whether someone should
get a bill or not and those algorithms
have been kind of like shown to be
really unfair
Okay so
I'm here kind of like
what I want to point out is generally
the traditional view of what's going on
is okay we're going to run a machine
learning algorithm we're going to run a
classifier here I just brought down the
linear classifier to make it pretty
simple and we can say okay well let's
look at how this classifier is going to
treat different populations and you can
say in this example it seems at a high
level that if you look at like what the
classifier is doing for group a like
Imagining the green people or people are
classified positively and one is doing
for Group B there is something a bit
sketchy going on and we have to worry
about this that's kind of like you know
how people traditionally think about
fairness and algorithmic fairness but
today I kind of like want to move away
from this a bit so generally the
question is like how do I make this one
classifier Affair but as you saw the
title of my talk is about pipelines and
so I'm going to try to convince you that
you shouldn't care about a single
decision and a single algorithm that you
should care about
a pipeline of many composed decisions in
real life it's almost never going to be
about a single decision that you're
going to be making about an individual
uh rather you're going to make several
decisions about someone you know
throughout their life for example and
those decisions they're going to affect
each other and they're going to compose
with each other
um like if I hear kind of like the
example that I have is an example
um in which I'm looking like for the
sake uh you know if this talk I'll look
at kind of like an education pipeline
I'm going to say well
what's going on here is that
um you know what preschool you're going
to go to is going to affect kind of like
your access to like what kind of like
elementary schools
um middle school high schools you can
get to that's going to affect your
college opportunities that's going to
affect your like job opportunities so
you can't just think about like what's
going on like one level of this pipeline
you have to think about the entire thing
um the point is that
inequality of access to opportunities in
those kind of pipelines can Arise at
like several of those points and they're
going to compose with each other
um you know like if I have like
disparities in my opportunities right
here okay I don't know how to use a
clicker I guess um if I have disparities
in like um you know opportunities right
here well this is going to kind of like
also affect your future access to
Opportunities if you have like disparity
in access to Opportunities right here
that might have been caused because of
like past disparities and inequalities
in access to opportunities in the past
um and you know in real life in the
education pipeline we know like those
disparities can really Arise at the very
very early level it's really hard to get
into a good preschool in the US for
example
that's kind of like what I want to model
today and then you know once you have a
pipeline like this the question is like
where are you going to intervene and you
know once again if you look at the
education pipeline I think it should not
be too hard to convince you that if
you're trying to intervene only at the
College admission level to try to fix
College admissions that's probably not
going to work it's probably not going to
be enough so you need to think about the
whole thing so it's maybe worth
intervening before in this pipeline
you know now if you're saying I'm going
to be intervening in this pipeline at
several possible stages of this pipeline
you now have to reason about wait what
are those interventions going to do how
are they going to compose with each
other and how do you optimally kind of
like design interventions like several
levels of this pipeline to kind of like
improve outcomes and to reduce
disparities over groups
um whatever that means and I'll get to
whatever that means in a bit because you
know there's also like possibly
different ways you could Define how you
want to improve and reduce those
disparities
um
before I get into the technical of the
talk I just want to point out that there
is some other really interesting work in
the space of kind of like composed
decisions In fairness especially those
three Works
um I'm sure there are others that I
probably forgot about but I also like
know that these people are here at
Simons this week so I just want to make
sure that I'm highlighting them as a
Christian Urban at some point and I know
that like uh Kevin is right here so yeah
but anyway so now let me start talking
about the math and talking about like
how we were modeling this
um before you tell me my model is wrong
I know my model is wrong it's a very
stylized model okay it's a very high
level stylized model so that we can like
try to think about those disparities
there's definitely a lot of ways you can
improve it so just remember this is
abstract
um and I'm not trying to claim that like
I've solved real life that's not true
okay
um but yeah and so kind of like here are
the points what we're trying like the
way we're going to model this is like
we're going to have well this pipeline
that's going to be comprised of like
several layers so we're going to have
this kind of a graphical model and let
me actually go through this model right
now
well the first thing is we're going to
say we're going to have like a first
starting layer right here it's going to
have a bunch of different nodes and
we're basically going to say those are
kind of like the starting populations
this is the kind of population you are
going to start you know your life in
this could be yeah okay so different
notes here are going to correspond to
different song populations it could be
like different social economic statuses
for example
and then you know you're gonna go from
the starting layer and you're going to
go through the layers one by one so
what's going to happen here is like each
of those layers they're going to
correspond to like possibly a different
stage of life
um and you know each node in that layer
is going to correspond to like an
outcome of this stage of light you can
imagine I don't know maybe layer K minus
one is your kind of like education after
um High School it could be that I don't
know one node is like you go to like
college uh one not could be that you
decide to you know get a job like right
after uh finishing
um high school for example
um
and finally what's going to happen is at
the end you're going to end up in this
final uh layer this final layer is going
to have like a reward pretty much which
is going to be like a measure of like
how good the outcome
um you're like you end up in it's like
the bigger like the bigger R is going to
be the better the outcome you can stay
here
so now I kind of like told you about the
layers I haven't told you how we're
going to move across different layers
but here for the sake of like you know
this model like for instance Simplicity
we're going to assume that we kind of
like have stochastic transitions so
there is some probability that if you
start then this node you're going to you
know end up like in this node on the
first layer and it's going to be given
by kind of like a transition Matrix here
M1 so a transition Matrix M1 is going to
basically tell you what is the
probability of being from a node on
layer one to a node on a layer two and
this is kind of like where you can like
start modeling disparities between
different groups because you can say oh
maybe like this one is like people of
like a really high like social economic
status and they have like a lot of like
high probability paths that go to kind
of like the best nodes in the graph
versus those people people have like a
really low economics like social
economic status they have access to
almost no opportunities so most of their
transitions are actually going to go
towards like the lower quality outcomes
in the graph for example so it's kind of
like uh how we're thinking about the
disparities in this model
so now we have a pipeline like this and
we want to intervene on this pipeline
what do we mean by interpreting on this
pipeline once again this is going to be
pretty
um you know this is going to be kind of
like pretty uh stylized but we're going
to look at the setting in which we have
like a centralized designer that can
decide how and where to intervene on
this pipeline possibly at several stages
at the same time
and like the intervention is they're
going to be able to change the
transition Matrix between you know any
two layers they want that's going to
come at the cost though you can't do
that for free the more you're going to
change the transition Matrix the more
costly it's going to be for you
so we're going to have discussed here
which is basically what I'm calling C of
mt0 to Mt here is the cost of going from
like an initial transition Matrix Mt
zero between layer we'll say t and c
plus one to going to a new transition
Matrix mft
um just for the sake of optimization I'm
going to assume this class function is
going to be convex because if it's not
complex we can't really say anything
um
and basically we're going to say that we
have a budget constraint across the
whole pipeline so you have some budget
that you can allocate across the
pipeline you need to decide how you're
going to split up this budget across
different stages of your pipeline and
how you're going to change the
transition at each stage so that's kind
of like the high level idea here
um yeah I was wondering uh if you make
any assumptions about how the costs
change uh through the pipeline so you
know is it easier to make interventions
early on in the pipeline versus later on
so okay so what I'm doing what I'm going
to be doing in most of this talk is
going to not make an assumption some
just like the surely algorithmic and so
how can I solve this pipeline later on
I'll talk a bit about kind of like what
happens in like a very special case of
Pipeline and which which is once again
stylized and unrealistic I'm going to
tell you about what happens when the
cost at every layer is the same which is
not really what happens in practice but
let me get back to this a bit later in
the talk yeah
okay so now
so I talked about the model you know
it's like our second contribution here
is to actually have dynamic programming
algorithms to find
approximately Optimal Solutions and this
problem
um and so basically what we're trying to
do here remember is like we need to
figure out how we're going to split this
total budget across different layers and
then each layer we need to figure out
how we're going to use this budget to
change the transition Matrix
um and so yeah
we're trying to do this optimally I
haven't told you about optimal means
here I haven't told you yet well it's
evolving here because we have two
different definitions of optimality that
are going to actually have different
properties here
um and the first one is say okay we want
to try to maximize the social welfare of
the population so you look at the sun
like a weighted sum by population size
of the utilities that people get when
they go through this Pipeline and you
say I'm trying to maximize this total
like utility
um and you know like social offer is
like a pretty common objective that's
used a lot in a lot of different fields
but I just want to point out that what
this is going to do is it's going to
tell you what's the best thing you can
do at the level of the whole population
uh it's not going to say anything about
any subpopulation it's not going to tell
you anything about how this welfare is
going to be split across different
populations so you might just end up in
a situation in which you just allocate
all of your resources to the very large
population and you completely ignore the
superposition that you should actually
care about
which is why we also have objective
number two which is the maximum welfare
and now we're trying to maximize the
welfare of the worst of population so
just saying you know I'm going to take
this transition matrices here so that if
you start in like if you start in the
population I well basically your utility
can be too low
so I'm trying to maximize these
quantities I'm trying to make sure that
like for every eye for every starting
population the utility you're going to
get in this population is not going to
be too low
[Music]
transition Matrix are there constraints
because I would imagine that like okay
at least some people would think that
some people get better off at the cost
of other people getting better off so
like if you're looking at the highest
socioeconomic status there's only so
many people only so many people can be
doctors
so there could be constraints I'm not
going to get into too much to talk about
this because they're kind of like all
abstracted away in the cost function but
like towards the end of the talk I'll
get back like a bit about this point and
like what kind of like yeah what can
happen there and like how uh like you
know like what kind of like settings
this setup can model so tell you a bit
more about this yeah
okay so now that I told you what the
model is it's time for math this is
gonna be the rest of the talk by the way
like everyone else had like really
amazing talks from like a lot of kind of
like super cool motivation really nice
lights and everything you're going to be
staring at pictures like this for the
rest of the talk so I I apologize in
advance
um
but yeah let me try to start with a very
simple setting in which I only have two
layers so it's like my it's not a
pipeline anymore it's just like a
one-time decision how do I want to solve
this problem okay well imagine so this
is like my starting populations this is
my endnote so here I have kind of like a
distribution over like you know what's
the probability you start with like a
high social economic status that would
be kind of like D1 here you start with
like a low research economic status so
this is just the probability
that are going to start in each of those
nodes
and then you know you go through the
transition Matrix and then you get those
playoffs if you end up like at node
number one you get R1 and you know it
keeps going this way
um and if you think about it that's
actually a really easy problem because
what am I trying to do here uh what I'm
trying to do and like here I'm talking
again to talk about the social welfare
not the Mini Max objective but the
Minimax objective is actually not going
to look very different in terms of
optimization but just part of the social
welfare well my social welfare is just
kind of like a linear function of the M1
matches here
that's just kind of like R times M1
times like the starting distribution
this is how much Social offer people are
going to get and you know now I have uh
convex budget constraint which is that I
just want to use my cost here uh to go
from MC lame one zero to M1 and I want
this cost to be less than my total
budget so nothing crazy it's a linear
program with a complex constraint and
some complex optimization you can solve
this not hard so far yeah well
oh sorry no I just didn't get the joke
uh can you go back one slide
for the past two days
um but yeah that was the joke
um anyway okay so now it's just like
telling you what happens when you have
one layer well when you have many layers
we're gonna go backwards and we're going
to start here and then we're going to
solve this layer and then we're going to
solve this layer I'm going to do some
dynamic programming backwards uh sounds
simple enough and a high level but there
is a worry here
because okay so imagine I want to start
at the last layer so I want to kind of
like find the best possible
um MK right here given that then I'm
going to skip quickly on this but I can
imagine I already know how much budget
I'm going to allocate to this layer I'm
going to call that okay well the problem
that I'm going to solve this can affect
the same as before it seems simple it's
a simple convex automation problem
um assuming you know
it's okay except that you don't know DK
because DK depends on the decisions that
you're going to make on the rest of the
pipeline that you haven't made yet
um so
it's going to depend on the early
Transitions and since we're solving from
the end we haven't we haven't solve for
this yet so it's kind of like why things
get a bit more complicated but so you
know since we don't know what the G of K
is going to be here what we can do is we
can try to guess it so we're going to
try to guess every possible JFK will
take an Epsilon net up here of like the
possible probability distribution over
those uh nodes sadly when you take this
Epsilon net well you know if you want an
Epsilon net and you have W nodes on each
layer well the size of the net is going
to be one over um Epsilon to the power
of w so if W is not constant it's going
to be really hard to do anything
um I'll get back to this in a bit that's
actually kind of like unavoidable
and you know then I'm gonna try every
single dfk on net I'm going to solve the
program for every possible D of K on the
Epsilon net and I'll go backwards
and so I'll go to the layer right before
I'll do the same thing and I'll say okay
well
here I'm guessing all the possible gfts
as before here I need to figure out what
the r of T is going to be what the
reward is going to be but you know there
is going to be one reward for each
Distribution on the Epsilon net that I
did in the previous layer
so I'm just going to have to go through
all of them but there's not going to be
that many of them you know there's just
going to be assuming that W is constant
I'm just going to have to deal with like
oops sorry uh one over Epsilon to the
power of w things here and like one uh
over Epsilon to the power of w things
here so now I can be bad but if W is
constant you can do this
um and here so yeah so you're just going
to use the solutions to the previous
steps at this point
um
finally quick thing is so far I'm
assuming that I know what budget DFC I'm
using at each time step it's actually
not too hard to figure out what that
budget is going to be you can also use
like a dynamic programming approach for
uh the budget you just discretize the
budget it's easy to discretize it's just
a one-dimensional scalar thing so you
just discretize the budget and every
time step I mean you know every like
level of the pipeline you guess the
possible budget you're going to be using
there and you'd try out kind of like all
of them but there is only a small number
but you have to try out so it's fine uh
yeah
hey is there a reason we can't do this
second BP approach first where we like
start at Ground one and discretize a
budget and say like solve this for every
uh Big B of Epsilon you you can start at
the beginning that doesn't change
anything you could don't know the
distribution for every like what BF
repsilon then
well if you if you started the begging
if you start from the first layer you
don't know the different the description
of rewards so you have to guess that no
matter which way you go you're gonna
have to guess one side but it's going to
be the same approach if you start from
the beginning
foreign
it's going to be approximately optimal
because we're just losing like uh like
napsilon roughly in terms of social
welfare each layer so we're just going
to lose K Epsilon total so we're going
to get like okay Epsilon approximation
if you have K transitions uh it's if
you're assuming that W is constant
you'll just need to kind of like solve
like one over Epsilon W problems to each
layer uh and you're only going to have
to do this K times so that will be
efficient
um and actually you know so it's like so
for once again like for w constant uh
but K could be very large it's like
cleaner in case so you could actually
technically think about like a very long
pipeline you just need the pipeline on
which at each level you're going to have
like a kind of like course grouping of
outcomes so that your Double U is not
too big
um and finally for the maximum objective
you can actually do exactly the same
approach it's just a bit more
complicated because now you actually
have to keep track uh instead of keeping
track of all the possible like
distributions TFT add a layer you need
to keep track of all like d of c i one
called dfti which is kind of like the
specific distribution for population I
so it's just going to give you kind of
like it's going to be the same approach
it's just going to give you like a
quadratic blow up in W which is a
constant here anyway so it's not really
going to change that much
okay so now I told you that there is
this W which is kind of like pesky and
annoying here
um because we have this dependency in
one over Epsilon to the power of w this
is actually just unavoidable
um it's the problem is hard for
non-mustion w
um and that can be seen via a production
to vertex cover in this case
um I'm sure most of you guys know what
vertex cover is but just to give you
like a quick example like okay what do I
want to do in vertex cover I want to
pick the minimum amount of vertices that
are going to cover this like a given
graph we're going to cover all of the
edges in the graph so in this case those
two vertices give you a Vertex cover
because the red one is going to cover
those two edges in red and the green one
is going to cover this like three edges
in green
and the reason we want to use vertex
cover is because well we I mean I'll
show you the reduction in a second but
vertex cover is a hard problem
um it's not just hard to exactly
optimize it's hard to approximately
solve uh vertex cover is not just NP
complete it cannot be approximated to a
constant Factor
and we'll use this to show that in our
problem we also cannot approximate our
solution to a constant Factor
this is kind of like what the reduction
is going to uh look like uh it looks a
bit scary but let me just go through
this it's actually not that complicated
this is a actually if you look at it
it's a very simple pipeline so don't
worry about those things they're just
here to make sure that the like
transition matrices are going to kind of
like sum up to one properly and
everything it's just like dominoes you
don't need to care about this what you
really want to care about is what's
going on here
and what I'm saying is like I'll take
every Edge UV in my original graph in on
the graph on which I'm trying to solve
my vertex cover problem and I'll say for
every Edge UV uh in my original uh graph
on which I'm trying to solver to
discover I'll kind of like assign a
starting population
I'll assign a song completion and I'll
assign two path to the end
when two path through the pipeline and
it's going to be one path that
corresponds to you there's going to be
one path that corresponds to D
so next one so far
what I'm going to tell you is okay so if
I want to do and here like the harness
result is like for the Minimax for in
this case just to clarify this but if I
actually want to get a good Minimax
furnace guarantee I need to make sure
that like from you know I get to a good
outcome of one rather than zero here
for every starting compilation but I
want to do this because you know I have
a limited budget I want to do this using
as few path as possible that's kind of
like where the vertex cover thing is
coming from now so you know I'm saying
here I could kind of like use this path
and I can spend Budget on this path and
like you know this is going to give me
um a good outcome here because I'll get
to one starting from
um UV here but that might not be the
best solution because if I have a
situation like this in which uh here
it's UV and here it's VW well they're
actually going to share that the path
right here and I should be using this
vpath instead of using a u-path and a
Double U path that's going to use more
budget it's going to be less efficient
so I kind of like want to use like the
minimum number of path but now what's
going on is when I pick a path picking a
path is the same as taking a vertex in
the original graph I'm telling you if
I'm picking this I'm actually putting V
in my vertex cover set so if I minimize
the number of paths I'm using well I'm
using as few vertices as possible in the
original problem and so this is how this
reduces to vertex cover
and so yeah and so this is why we kind
of like have this hardness result that
we're not going to be able to
approximate to a constant factor in this
case
um
finally kind of like the last thing that
I want to mention
um is that we also kind of like have
results on kind of like the price of
fairness because we're trying to
understand you know the gathers going to
be between those two different
objectives what happens when you're
trying to optimize social welfare versus
when you're trying to optimize the
minimum utility uh of across the
different populations and this is where
I was telling you okay this is another
kind of like analystic case because here
I'm going to assume that there is a
linear cost of one by like if you want
to change the transition by one and it's
going to be true everywhere in the
pipeline in practice you kind of like
also want to think about pipelines where
um you know like the closest you are to
the end the harder is going to correct
for past disparities and I guessing
going to become more and more costly
um and just there I just want to point
out that we actually have kind of like
tied Downs uh on what this price of
fairness is going to be
and there's like three different cases
there that are for kind of like very
very small B this one is not that
interesting it's a bit of a corner case
I'm not going to cover this really there
is another case which is for a very
large B it's
trivial
if you think about it for a second
some kind of like going to focus on like
this intermediate case which is kind of
like interesting because showing some
interesting structure like how you can
actually intervene on such pipelines
um and so let me look at what's going on
there like give you some intuition of
why we have this dependency on like w
over B
um
so okay so imagine again I kind of like
have this whole pipeline and remember
and I'm like in the special case here
we're intervening here has the same cost
as intervening here right
uh one thing I can try to do is actually
just forget about all of this and
intervene at the end if I intervene in
the beginning and I change my
transitions with bargaining there's
still going to be a lot of transitions
left that are going to push me back
towards possibly bad outcomes uh might
not help me that much if I intervene at
the end on the last layer here you would
be like well you know I can actually
have a lot of control on like what
reward people are going to end up in
um okay
so really what I want to do is I want to
push people as much as possible towards
this reward and if I kind of like want
to hear
um
guarantee that every population is going
to kind of like get like a reasonable
social welfare I can just make say that
like for every node on this layer I'm
going to increase the transition by B
over w
um if I do this I'm guaranteeing that
you know everyone is being too short but
like one of those notes anyway here so
at this point with probability B over
you're going to increase the probability
of everyone going to the highest reward
by B over W always and so you know
you'll get a mean Max Worth or that's
going to be at least B over W Times R1
the highest reward
if you want to compare this to the
social welfare well the best social
welfare you could get is like if somehow
you manage to get everyone to R1 that's
good and you would get like a social
offer of R1 and so that's why you have a
price of fairness that's going to be at
must be over W in this case
um
and it's actually kind of like tight
um here we're not going to get into like
two yeah
the highest reward is
yeah I'll get to this in a second I'm
assuming that everyone wants the same
highest reward which is another
assumption of the model right like if I
was thinking about education
um
yeah I completely agree yeah it's just
like that's that's why I'm saying this
is a very stylized model it's like a
first step
uh yeah no I mean like I mean I haven't
made any progress on this so far because
this is definitely one of the directions
that I've been interested in like
working on in this case I just don't
have good insights for you right now I'm
about to solve this but yeah
kind of like
we're all going to have the last couple
slides once again saying that this is a
stylish model it's not completely
realistic
um one thing that you may complain about
and so would be a very valid complaint
is oh well you know if I look at this
graph well different populations are
going to face if population one like
population one population two get to
this node then they're going to face the
same Transitions and say that's not what
happens in practice uh if you come from
different subpopulations you can get to
the same point in life and still face
different opportunities
um so what happens there uh and one
thing that you want to point out is we
can actually model this in our setting
we can duplicate this pipeline you can
duplicate the nodes so that instead of
having just like uh one node for each
outcome in a layer you have one node for
each outcome and string compilation
and the way you can link those together
and Link those interventions together is
by cannot like playing with a cost
function and having the cost function
such that you know if you modify your
transition Matrix from one population it
becomes cheaper to modify for another
population so you kind of like want like
the cost function is set up so that it's
going to naturally make you kind of like
change the transition for several
populations at the same time so this is
one way you can model this
um it's just going to be kind of like
giving us a quadratic blow up in our
algorithms because now you have a
pipeline that's going to be like bigger
before it was like only double you know
it's not going to be W Square because
you know it's going to be W outcomes
times w
starting populations
um okay but this is something we can
kind of like handle here uh this is one
thing and there's a million other things
we can think about to try to extend this
model improve this model one thing is
like it's weird to assume that
transitions are going to be stochastic
because people do make decisions in real
life and people are going to be trying
to like go towards specific nodes so it
would be interesting to model what
happens when you actually have this kind
of like strategic elements there
um we don't have any feedback loops it's
a really Asic click model here so you go
from beginning to the end and once you
reach the end that's it the problem is
over against we're not taking into
account how this is going to affect kind
of like the next population for example
but there's not anything you could model
um
so I knew this one's for you uh we have
a very simplified model in which
everyone wants the same rewards but you
know uh not everyone in life wants the
same outcomes not everyone gets the same
utility for getting to the same none
getting the same outcome
um
another thing is we're assuming there is
one centralized designer who can
intervene on the whole pipeline but in
real life you know each of those
different levels of pipeline people are
going to be doing their own thing
they're not going to have like one
centralized person who's actually
changing the transition to that whole
pipeline
um you know
um
another interesting Direction I think
would be if someone has real data and
wants to kind of like try to see if you
can model this pipeline using real data
that'll be real interesting
many others
um but basically that's kind of like all
I wanted to mention today so like once
again yeah thanks for coming to my talk
[Applause]
hi Duke hey
is this on yeah it is on hijiva I really
enjoyed the talk
um if it's okay I have a two-part
question okay one
um when you're doing the model did you
think about uh getting allowing people
to get utility from intermediate layers
so rather than the ultimate wire and my
second question is uh yeah like capacity
constraints on nodes or like maybe like
the utility from one node goes down as
more people enter it or possibly
increases uh okay let me talk about
those two things uh number one I believe
is easy
um
because
you can just if you have intermittent
rebars at each layer you can just kind
of like
a few slides give me a sec
um
you know like when you're solving this
kind of problem here you can slightly
modify the objective to take into
account that you actually have like an
additional reward there it's like having
a bunch of masks you're just like yeah
you have like you know you have your R1
plus some intermediate reward it's not
going to change the problem by much
you're still going to be able to solve
this so that's fine uh question number
two I actually spent some time uh
thinking about uh capacity constraints
in this problem at some point and like
you know kind of like settings in which
the difficulty to like go to a specific
node the next layer is also going to
depend on number of people that end up
going there and like that kind of
transition and it was very hard to think
about an amazing the zero
progressiveness but you have like a good
idea to try to solve this that would be
a very interesting future interaction I
agree
uh yeah just a comment there seems like
a sort of congestion game if you think
capacities into account
so when I'm talking here about kind of
like those tragic elements and
everything I actually at some point was
thinking about like trying to model this
as a congestion game but it's really
hard to think about because you're
thinking about a congression gaming
you're thinking about how is the
equilibrium of the game going to change
when you're changing the capacities or
transitions or costs in the game uh and
I was only able to make progress on this
in like very special cases that are kind
of like trivial not that interesting so
yeah
foreign
but since you motivated this talk using
like algorithmic fairness and saying how
algorithms can be unfair so are you
assuming anywhere in the system that
there's algorithms evolved or I feel
like everything here doesn't really have
to do with algorithm well right so like
the point is like the transition
matrices are kind of like a way to
really abstract away once again so this
is very stylized like we're really
distracting away from like the process
by which people end up from like
um you know like node one and like layer
one to node one and Layer Two uh so you
can kind of like try to think about
those transitions are as transitions
that are induced by real decision making
process like processes by real
algorithms but like we're not explicitly
modeling this here this doesn't
necessarily have to be algorithms the
transition it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be algorithms it could
be kind of like just decisions and
everything but it's yeah also depends on
your definition of algorithm because I
would say that you know something like
you know you want to get into college
and you have to like sat or in the GRE
those are technically kind of like
algorithms that map here like inputs to
my score that is supposed to predict how
qualified you are for uh the job sorry
for the University yeah
so uh so I probably should have asked
this a lot earlier but uh compare this
model to just uh constrain Markov
decision process finite Horizon because
it looks very similar it is absolutely
it's just one that happens to be very
structured so we can actually
say something about it just because you
have like this kind of like really nice
layered structure but it is a markup
decision process yeah but then I'm
wondering where exactly the hardness
comes from right because they're you
usually have like uh polynomial time
algorithms like dynamic programming is
like super nice but
so
at first I should admit that like I'm
not an expert in results in Mark of the
student processes but I think like if
you look at them in a whole like full
generality they can still be hard to
solve right here just I think the
difficulty is really just coming from
the fact that
um what's happening is the number of
possibilities you get each time is kind
of like blowing up exponentially and
like the size of those layers and like
making things you know worse every time
just intuitively at a very high level
right
yeah and I guess the council comes from
the fact that you're using these very
general convex coasts as well we're also
using very general convex costs in that
sense so it's kind of like yeah I think
if you have like simpler costs it might
actually be
like easier to kind of like solve this
problem for example the posts would be
composable like column wise for the
foreign
this
where is this uh
this is using linear costs very simple
costs
so there may be some class of costs that
have like a nice structure that just
composed perfectly and everything works
out fine but even very simple cars like
cleaner cars seem to be hard so yeah
I see I see very cool thank you
but I was wondering you kind of
motivated your talk by saying well we
have these pipelines where like perhaps
we want to think about intervening at
the beginning rather than just at one
particular step but then in your very
simple model with a stylized one where
you're looking at price of fairness
you're like let's let's ignore all the
earlier ones and just look at the last
layer so can you say a little bit about
like if we wanted a very simple stylized
version of your already stylized model
that captures that effect like what what
would you include that's not kind of in
that right right yeah and so no that's a
really good question like this thing is
just really for the sake of example and
uh like the only reason you can do this
here is because the costs here are like
the same as the cost of the beginning
but you would imagine that in real life
if like the cost you're like much
cheaper and the cost here are going to
kind of like be much higher then you're
going to try to balance out you'll like
the layers at the end because you have
more control over the transitions but
you'll spend more like less on them
because it's too costly to do so and
you're going to start splitting more uh
one way you can actually see this is if
you look at like a very super simple
pipeline which is just a bunch of paths
like this person goes this way and this
person goes this way and this person
goes this way and you say okay it's kind
of like not costly at the beginning it's
very costly at the end on this path if
you want to maximize kind of like the
probability of like transitioning to
kind of like uh like say R1 I mean yeah
uh there so you know it would be kind of
like a like a very simple binary case
like you're either one or zero and like
you're trying to increase your
probability to go to one you want to
increase every level of this path
because kind of like a convex the
argument it's like better to split your
budget across the path rather than like
using all the budgets in one layer we
are going to do this in a way that kind
of like also depends on uh yeah how much
cost that is so you're gonna put less
weights on this last thing at the end
because it's becoming uh like way more
costly so like in traditionally that's
what's going on
okay uh let's take further questions
offline thank you very much oh thanks
for having me